ok can I can ask you about the updates
because you know hopefully like I said
hopefully we're gonna go over a thousand
dollars very soon and I certainly want
to use that as a benchmark to let me
take this opportunity to personally
guarantee that you will go over a
thousand dollars in the next several
minutes though I can't take a credit
card while we're maybe we'll okay I just
hard for me to talk your during
interview while act is awesome okay i'm
going to buy many downloads right now
but destiny he believes in the dream
baby believes in a dream that's it I do
what I do wow this is cool okay yeah i
see we can take a moment and then we can
share any pause this yeah we know what
you're really cool thank you that's
awesome huh thanks please that's really
awesome um that we can continue I can do
this I'm our next one moment